all right it's launched I've been
playing with the beta for a little bit
all of you need to go immediately and
sign up for your threads account I think
the big thing is like everyone's gonna
be like is this a Twitter killer it's
not a Twitter killer the world is about
and not or for everybody here whether
you like the idea whether you like meta
whether you like threads or not go sign
up figure it out go try
it's incredibly important that you go
and try new things with whether you end
up liking it or not is completely
irrelevant
key when there's new platforms that
matter that come out is you tasting it
you trying it so this is not a headline
of like threads versus Twitter they'll
both exist this is can you go on there
and use your Instagram Community to
create a new environment a lot of you
missed the Twitter thing don't
understand the Twitter thing and maybe
this is your opportunity to try it out
so
don't get into the debate get into the
trying new and trying to build your
audience and bring value that